PewDiePie and Simmons's kids play I got
a cow a girl I got a bearded man I got
at least nipple you got a name I got a
doctor player I got a dog I could eat it
come here let me eat you you look like a
penis face and I say that in the nicest
way possible
what do you try to say about my penis it
looks like a thumb I kind of look that's
what I say about your penis face I'll
get a shot it fly nipple face nipple
face well this is wrong with your face
just pick one wait Nick oh I don't know
which one I never had so much to
selection before I guess I go over this
way I like to kick it I like it rough I
like it rub it
slap that nipple left that's getting
hard and will be hardest diamonds once
I'm done with it oh my god too much yeah
I know
all right you go you [ __ ] you I hate
you oh if you touch it
put my nipple in it rub it
Tammy baby thank you so much okay I get
it
you're supposed to save man no wait did
No yeah I suck me that cat just sucked
me of course he did you're a nipple
everybody wants a second yeah let me
find you baby
famiiy baby I knew it oh yeah yeah Jimmy
okay I got ya that has to be good that
has to be a plus plus plus plus plus
plus least minimum mhmm come on where is
that where is it
every time Caine every goddamn time mate
nipples oh god I I missed one can oh I'm
sorry I'm sorry can you never look at
the a plus plus plus plus what we got
the time today anyway my god you know
what if you weren't such a [ __ ] we
would have gotten a Plus long ago yeah
we're not getting any more nipple for me
what the [ __ ] I want a present we did it
Oh goo get down over there crap oh no if
we never got in the clock we could've
gotten the clock no we would never have
gotten the clock you're having nipple
face how would you even know have no
idea where I am I can fly you a little
[ __ ] Oh God
that akkad know I knew all the [ __ ]
way about the wigs duck Oh God which I
can it Smit sense why do we always
pulling these stupid traps
no it's activate how how help Oh God oh
yeah dump our Demi nipple power don't
jump on my face
how are you still all thanks I got it ah
Punjab yeah hey man thanks
no I was gonna take it no let me go let
me go let me go yeah you flew too close
to the Sun it gave me I'm gonna [ __ ]
do it
go Icarus what we gotta pack this up for
[ __ ] you still got it even though your
nipple face I mean I've kind of had
still got it packed with chewing my tips
but like I still can still chat alright
alright let's do it one two a one two
three four cha-cha-cha cha cha cha cha
cha cha cha cha you're up tempo come on
jacha-chacha-chacha-chow bye jack
alright we got it
oh wow I like they were improvised sure
more of that in the stage and we'll be a
star one day you told us that I have
diarrhea oh god oh god
put it back you symptoms in get rid your
bumpy nips you moisture them it's that
what you do is everything alright
it's everything all right there what are
you doing
God dang it Kenny get your [ __ ] to get
stuff infinite loop of death how do we
get rid of that ever again okay we did
it now that might need to go say to that
alright you turn it up when I'm ready or
you do that yarn is mine oh god yeah
penis penis go penis penis you're my
favorite penance go finish go our penis
are equal after a and we're both famous
that's what all matters my nipples are
[ __ ] famous my duck is finally famous
I know oh sorry
delicate hands now there's never a dull
moment with you at the heaven separate
maybe like twice I gotta hand it to you
you've got quite the unbreakable spirit
I mean I'm not nearly as brave as you if
I was in your capably nimble shoes I'd
say to heck with Hattie and my friends
they'll be fine and then I pack myself a
nice bag lunch show these cats my
favourite finger make like horse turds
and hit the trail but I'm not you and
you're not horse turds now those hairs
you are the very definition of the cat's
PJ's and speaking of which these cats
are truly bizarre why are they here I
mean I've got my theories perhaps
they're aids from another world
maybe they're genetic experiments gone
awry what could it be that they were
once normal kitties normal kitties who
evolved into the strange unpleasant
creatures we see before us probably
hideously adorable abominations with
their beady eyeballs giants bloodthirsty
tiny mouths fangs /e paul claws and
stanky funk breath plus they're awfully
rude and crabby I think they all need
girlfriends I'm a cat G I'm grouchy see
I like to run around all day and hurt
people's feelings
see but don't take them lightly no sassy
and lazy by Nature cats are awfully
crafty and finding a weak spot in that
bright horns furry armor might prove
difficulty - the why they're always
watching children I see them lurking in
the shadows lurking hard are hardly
lurking say on that note this whole
theater is like a bad joke but how did
things get so bad at one time smiles on
everyone's mouth faces can you believe
it I wouldn't believe it
I mean if you
told me that had more than likely call
you a liar and walk away and I'm find
someplace to get ice cream to replenish
the innocence you blackened with your
filthy disease I like strawberry just
keep your wits about you as you descend
deeper into the belly of the beast and
perhaps you'll find a way to put an end
to this madness
so we're supposing ice cream is that is
that it I think that's it I hope so
all right you know what i'ma buy a gift
come here [ __ ] I'll make you feel
better
[Music]
private chef what else you got a hobo oh
but if you want add go jog on that hair
though what else you want a dead guy Sam
be a snorkel guy I take that a mousse
there's a beard man a cow what mom bacon
face
get out of here bacon face like you're
so amazed like we could just be amazed
at each other okay I can't believe it do
you believe what Becca said about Sarah
last night no way like oh my god David
BFF since kindergarten and nowadays
and you know what I was like
what I'm saying right yeah tell you what
the contest's go with little little
hairs
I thought about dead ones and then I
couldn't step that right only kidney
space I made his face one and I'm like
it looks like a testicles and I'm like
I'm so shocked by chance
yeah well you never gonna stab now
either Becky oh wait you're not Becky
get your [ __ ] out of here Becky
[Applause]